what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
more spider-man news however today we
are talking about tom holland spider-man
specifically and spider-man 4. yesterday
we talked about andrew garfield
spider-man and the sony spider-man
universe but today we will be talking
about our main mcu spider-man tom
holland and his contract with disney and
sony however we are also going to be
talking about the relationship between
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios and sony because we also talked
about yesterday how kevin feige is going
to be helping sony with their spider-man
projects but we just learned that kevin
feige kind of issued a warning to sony
he warned them about a very specific
thing with their spider-man universe in
fact it looks like he kind of
discouraged them from going too big too
quickly and now we know that he is
working with sony on the spider-man
project so a lot to talk about today
including clearing up some reports that
may make people a little bit nervous
about the future of spider-man but if
you want to stay up to date on
spider-man and the mcu be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos and speaking of
spider-man if you're looking to grab
some spider-man g-fuel or any of their
other collectors boxes like moon knight
or doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness you can use code cosmic for 30
off right now at g fuel dot com until
july 11th so we'll get into kevin feige
warning sony about something but first
let's talk about tom holland spider-man
and spider-man 4. a report came out last
night that worried people a little bit i
got a lot of dms and tweets but
hopefully this video kind of sets your
mind at ease to start off with it's
important to know that kevin feige and
amy pascale producer over at sony after
spider-man no way home came out they
both announced together that they are
already working on the next spider-man
film spider-man 4 for the mcu with tom
holland zindaya and jacob batalon and
they specifically said that the reason
they already came out and said this is
so that fans would not have to worry
about the relationship between sony and
disney and marvel studios and worry
about spider-man still being in the mcu
because if you were following spider-man
a few years ago after spider-man far
from home we were kind of uncertain on
whether or not spider-man was going to
be remaining in the mcu and it looked
like marvel studios and sony were kind
of breaking up but then they formed a
new deal and everything ended up all
right but that is why kevin feige and
amy pasquale told us that a new one is
being worked on so we don't have to
worry having said that it looks like tom
holland hasn't actually signed a new
deal for spider-man 4 yet and this has
fans worried this report comes from jeff
snyder via the ankler and here's what he
had to say okay so sony may not have the
biggest bench in terms of franchises but
it wisely made a deal with marvel
studios to get its marquee character
spider-man into the mcu which helped
make the studio's solo spidey movies
must seize even more so and while plans
are in motion for another spidey trilogy
starring tom holland i don't believe he
has actually signed a deal yet so those
plans remain unofficial for now that
said i'm sure that more spidey
adventures with tom holland are a top
priority for rothman and co and he is
speaking about the executives at sony
there and he continues to say which is
also counting on him as the anchor of
its budding uncharted franchise as well
so even though plans are in place it
looks like tom holland has not signed a
deal for spider-man 4 5 or 6 yet now
like i said this worries some people but
you really don't have to worry i would
be completely and utterly shocked if tom
holland did not sign a new contract with
sony and marvel studio disney and also
there's a very good point made at the
end of this quote and report where
snyder says that sony is also counting
on tom holland to be the anchor of its
uncharted franchise which makes a ton of
sense sony is putting a lot into that
franchise and tom holland is the star of
it and he's also their spider-man star
and although tom holland hasn't
technically signed a deal for another
spider-man movie or trilogy i would be
shocked if he didn't so fans don't
really have much to worry about here in
my personal opinion however yesterday we
talked about kevin feige getting
involved with sony's spider-man universe
which is a very good thing now they
pretty much consult kevin feige a little
bit on all of their projects that are
related to spider-man that is but now it
looks like they're going a little bit
deeper with consulting kevin feige as i
stated yesterday he is going to be
helping them out with their universe but
a new report states that kevin feige
kind of told them to slow down a bit in
this same report from snyder at the
ankler he reports and reveals that kevin
feige is said to have previously warned
sony not to get too ahead of itself in
terms of building some larger universe
with the s-u-m-c which of course stands
for sony universe of marvel characters
and it also says that he still offers
notes on all sony's marvel films and
this makes perfect sense it makes
perfect sense in two different ways one
it just makes sense that marvel studios
president would work with sony on their
marvel films but two kevin feige kind of
started his career working on spider-man
films i think some maybe most know that
kevin feige started with marvel with the
x-men films and the spider-man sam raimi
toby mcguire films he didn't have any
major role during those times but he was
learning and he was helping which
eventually led to him being president of
marvel studios so through the sam raimi
trilogy kevin feige was there with sam
raimi and with toby maguire so kevin
feige has been extremely close to
spider-man since the live-action
adaptations so who better to have
consult with their universe than the man
who's been there from the beginning and
the president of marvel studios and his
advice is 100 right sony should not get
too ahead of himself in terms of
building this huge huge spider-man
universe with a bunch of different
projects trying to connect them all
together we've seen another studio kind
of be bad at this warner brothers dc
universe and it kind of seems like
that's exactly what they did they went
too big too fast i mean they started off
with a justice league movie rather than
doing a few individual movies before
then and taking a few years to build
everything up they jumped right in and
the universe didn't turn out too hot and
even right now they're kind of
struggling with what to do of course it
doesn't really help that ezra miller and
amber heard have been in the spotlight
for not so good reasons lately but the
point is they did rush the universe and
that's what kevin feige is telling sony
don't do that don't rush the mcu started
in 2008 with iron man and between iron
man and the avengers there were four
years in between and five movies in
between the incredible hulk iron man 2
thor captain america the first avenger
and then the avengers in 2012. they took
their time they didn't introduce too
many characters just the core of the
avengers and characters like black widow
and hawkeye got introduced in other
films not their own films and they did
it right and that is what kevin feige is
telling sony and if there is anybody who
knows how to build a huge cinematic
universe and bring it all together it's
kevin feige now the good news is is that
sony hasn't really gone and built
anything super huge yet it seems like
they kind of had plans but maybe kevin
feige's advice slowed him down just a
bit yes sony has been making spider-man
movies over the years but as far as a
connected universe is concerned venom is
kind of the first thing they really did
and of course we're not talking about
the spider-man homecoming trilogy we
don't really count that because that
takes place in the mcu although sony is
kind of taking a few characters selected
characters and bringing them into their
own universe but we know that they're
going to have a different spider-man
than tom holland so we'll have to wait
and see then they tried morbius which
failed now the pandemic really screwed
this up and it kind of seems like after
they filmed it they kind of changed
their mind on the direction they wanted
to go so they did reshoot so it was kind
of set up to fail it's not really its
fault but now we have craven the hunter
coming we have madame webb we have a
spider woman project there are some
upcoming things that make you wonder if
they are going a little bit too fast but
the good news is that they are
consulting with kevin feige and he has
warned them about going too fast and
again he is somebody that you should
definitely take advice from and i know
amy pascal over at sony definitely
values his opinion that's how we got tom
holland spider-man in the mcu kevin
feige told sony amazing spider-man 3
with andrew garfield isn't going to work
you're gonna have to let me do it at
marvel studios and bring spider-man into
the mcu which is what happened and then
spider-man became a massive success so
with kevin feige helping sony with their
spider-man projects and with both marvel
studios and sony really wanting tom
holland back and already working on a
fourth spider-man film i would not worry
at all about tom holland returning to
play spider-man in the mcu and hopefully
with kevin feige helping sony out with
their spider-man universe that universe
will be pretty great as well but hey let
me know what you think about this news
in the comments down below what do you
want to see in spider-man 4 and from the
sony universe of marvel characters let
me know and don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest marvel news you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof